bonjour je suis vraiment très très
content d'être ici parmi vous et
jeunesse assez dynamique et pagny
heureuse vraiment je suis très contente
alors quand j'ai des multiples
casquettes je me suis dit de quoi je
vais pas renier aujourd'hui de la
culture comme suit des tris de la santé
conditions orthophoniste et de troupes
donc après mûre réflexion je me suis dit
allez on parle de la créativité de du
rêve de l'imagination et ma première
question qu'est-ce que escaut parmi vous
quelqu'un qui voulait par exemple après
sa maîtrise au son diplôme créé une
entreprise crée une entreprise 3 ou 4 5
6 d'accord super alors est ce que
quelqu'un parmi vous voulez créer une
association ou être membres dans une
association ou être active dans la vie
associative dont la société civile or 12
bravo alors le problème là c'est pas un
problème mais pourquoi créer une
entreprise
c'est vraiment 4 5 ou 6 et pour
l'association et la vie associative
presque tous où tout là notre société
parce qu'on a cet immense peur de
l'échec parce que un arabe à nam nam
raffour mainline sauvegarder mener à
l'échec
et là c'est notre culture c'est notre
éducation malheureusement
parce que avoir peur de quelque chose je
vous assure que le chèque ou la peur de
l'échec n'existe pas premièrement donc
il faut tout d'abord avoir une bonne
estime de soi apprendre à voir une bonne
confiance ce soir
et là tout s'ouvre devant nous parce que
même même au départ on fait 2 2 on ne
peut pas réussir tout ce qu'on fait mais
à la fin on aura quand même un résultat
positif
il faut croire en soi il faut avoir une
bonne estime de soi el-assad
ça ne vient pas parachutée où c'est
l'éducation c'est la famille c'est
l'environnement familial et c'est le don
torah c'est le code aussi c'est
l'éducation
malheureusement fitounais en tunisie on
assez typique en tunisie on a cette idée
que on a peur de l'échec
on doit être vraiment en perfection dont
tout ce qu'on fait alors que c'est par
les cas un hamastan odom au début
j'étais une fille très frégate est très
réservé mes parents vraiment ne fait pas
ça il faut pas faire ça il faut faire
attention et après je me suis dit c'est
pas possible d'apprendre après mon bac
je me suis dit mon père la première
chose ma fille tu te tuer très fragile
il faut faire attention mais tbhc
l'enseignement me tabary met à bas âge
mental vraiment maranello hachey ne sont
bonnes et je fis une orientation et je
suis heureuse d'être orthophonistes et
des tripes psychologue pour enfants
parce que j'adore les enfants et femmes
de la manne j'excelle dans mon travail
et dans d'autres domaines mais juste
parce que j'ai eu confiance en moi j'ai
eu 7 c déclic c'est déclic en moi
c'était pas mon environnement
bon c'est vrai que aussi mais mais mais
j'ai eu le déclic ça m'a ça m'a fait
vraiment passé beaucoup d'étapes et j'ai
réussi dans tout ce que près
ce que je réussis malgré que qui a d
échec mais l'échec
je ne mets sur le compte de la réussite
parce que sur ça dans chaque échec on
réussit quelque part on apprend alors et
là aussi le nôtre environnement familial
lorsqu on était enfants dès la naissance
il y a des choses taboues nous nallet ya
pas deux il faut pas il est des
questions taboues il ya deux il faut pas
rêver il nous même l'imagination
on n'est pas né on n'est pas dans un
environnement où on nous encourage pour
imaginer pour la création pour la
richesse
je ne parle pas là de la richesse
côté argent 1 c'est plutôt la richesse
de l'âne la richesse de l'esprit c'est
beaucoup plus important que la richesse
côté financier ça arrive ça bien sûr
c'est une nécessité mais c'est
secondaire par rapport aux autres hommes
aux autres richesses lorsque je parle de
l'éducation malheureusement lorsque je
vois maintenant les jeunes
pourquoi ils sont pas creative zen vous
moi j'ai vu aujourd'hui jeunesse
vraiment tableau bravo est vraiment suis
très contente très contente
il faut continuer comme ça parce que la
tunisie a besoin de vous parce que la
tunisie nous a tout donné
tous nos attentes nos conseils et
maintenant c'est à nous elle souffre la
tunisie souffre aller en détresse et
c'est à nous maintenant
bennati aura de morale de desmaures a
new way a dit mme hanoune oui a dit même
pas de masse grasse aaa vous à notre
jeunesse là parce que vous êtes futurs
parents et donc comment éduquer les
enfants et pendant que alors les enfants
on apprend dès la naissance d'autres
saône a dit tout ce que tous ces zooms
avant cinq ans l'intelligence de
l'enfance écrit en avance 50 % avant
cinq ans 70 % avant 6 ans et le 30%
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans donc c'est très
important
l'environnement et l'entourage familial
avant avant 6 ans 5 6 ans dans notre
culture de notre éducation on n'a pas
cette mentalité on n'a pas cette
éducation
voilà on est bon des enfants ne
connaissent rien les bébés surtout
jusqu'à l'âge de 5 ans on s'occupe
côté nourriture proprété et tout ça mais
côté communication côté veste l'enfant
imaginez laisse l'enfant poser des
questions les
l'enfant rêver on n'a même pas cette
mentalité mais cette mentalité là et non
plus à l'école donc et de là comment on
oblige ou en critique où nos jeunes et
on leur dit pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
créatif pourquoi vous n'aime pas faire
des choses où vous n'imaginez pas des
choses si ils n'ont ils n'étaient pas
habitués à ça donc c'est très important
d'être créative et d'être en parlant de
l'école aussi qu'est ce qu'on fait à
l'école
bon c'est vrai que les enseignants les
professeurs ont des maîtrises des
doctorats mais ils n'apprennent pas la
façon des données délaissant au dd
laissant aux jeunes aux enfants